people should be Johnson more I don't
know about the ratings you know I love
land or a lot of people don't really and
or when I did the thing with the jazz
musicians that did Landers great
two-line poem on love on grief on every
human thing time sprinkles leafy's water
with his wing that a wing can sprinkle
as well as fly on love on grief on every
human thing time sprinkles leafies water
with his wing and you know he's telling
you to put your teeth on your lip three
times you know he's probably not even
thinking about it but happens you i love
i'm grieved
an every human thing times sprinkles
leafy's water with his wing and then the
second line doing water with his wing
it's really great writing as small as a
poem could be yeah and it's a very very
moving
I think that the young poets I mean over
ate all their contemporaries and
everybody alive I feel like I'm
representing some old idea of the art
when I recite Johnson and landed to you
I made quite gifted poets who really if
you've handed about older poetry they'll
they'll say oh you mean like Malini
Decker and Mary Ann Moore and William
Carlos Williams they the whole history
of the things so I think that the
president is overrated always certainly
it is at the moment because it's it's
evanescent you know it's not gonna last
that long
Elizabeth Bishop is already pretty much
outlasted one Monroe I bet a young
person like you doesn't have a native of
one Monroe was at one time in American
popular culture the two most important
categories of entertainer work ruler and
bandleader those are the two things to
be crooner bandleader one person was
both very prominent is both his name was
von Monroe he was born the same year as
Elizabeth Bishop and for a good part of
their lives if you asked anybody who's
more famous von Monroe or Elizabeth
Bishop it's how Fort Monroe for sure I
dare say that right at this second
within a few miles of us there many
hundreds of people are thinking that
Elizabeth Bishop and probably you and I
are the only two think about wall Monroe
and you don't know diddly about me
it's very hard to say what makes
anything any human being does survive
what did I get from my grandparents and
my great-grandparents what are my kids
grandparents gonna know about me or care
about that me and my generation have
done most guesses at that are at least a
little bit off often they're
terrifically off and yet as an animal as
a species entirely dependent on things
that are transmitted from generation to
generation the technology that you and I
are using right now is part of the human
need to pass things on beyond any one
lifetime we developed song and poetry
and dance and religion and storytelling
and a whole host of things to keep
things going what are the best marriage
customs who are the best burial customs
what should you eat when all of this the
animal is dependent upon it the animal
is a very ineffective animal except for
that ability to remember longer than its
own lifetime and yet to predict what to
use an internet word what the content
will be it's very mysterious and then we
use these words like sting and
immediately that we got from the dead
and only rarely do we begin to
understand even a little about their
insides and their history that's that's
life
you